hostile actually hostile
so funny story that actually happened to
me in court and i also punched the
witness
[Music]
hey legal eagles d james stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
so you can crush
law school you know growing up i loved
watching
legal movies there's nothing better than
seeing great lawyers stick it to evil
corporations or
obstreperous witnesses it's one of the
reasons that i went to law school and
became a trial lawyer myself
and now that i've been an attorney at a
major law firm for over 10 years i
thought i'd take some time and review
some of the most
famous legal scenes from movie history
so let's dive right in the first scene
comes from one of the most famous
courtroom scenes of all time
in a few good men
defense will be calling airmen cecil
o'malley and airman anthony rodriguez
they were working to ground crew at
andrews at 2 a.m on
7. your honor these men weren't on the
list rebuttal witnesses you're on our
call specifically to refute testimony
offered under direct examination
uh so this is actually fairly accurate
um
one of the things that people don't know
about trial is that
there there's so much you have to do
before you go into the courtroom
it takes weeks and sometimes months to
prepare your pre-trial filings
and one of the things that you have to
do is you have to tell the other side
uh what evidence you're going to present
and what witnesses you're going to call
and what kevin bacon is doing here is
he's saying that these witnesses were
not on the disclosures
from the defense and therefore they
shouldn't be allowed and
uh in normal circumstances that would be
the case if they weren't disclosed then
the judge would be correct in
disallowing those witnesses
however there's an exception to this
which is where you are
calling witnesses that are specifically
to rebut
the evidence that was presented by the
other side you effectively didn't know
that you had to call these witnesses and
they're only there to rebut the evidence
so this is actually a part of trial law
that you don't really
see in movies very much hearkening back
to all those pre-trial filings so this
is actually fairly accurate
i'll allow the witnesses this is
ridiculous
colonel a moment ago check the tower
logs for christ's sake
i would not expect a witness to opine
from the stand like that
they usually are only allowed to speak
when a question is presented to them
uh and uh tom cruise would have been
within his rights to object and to move
to strike the statement as
non-responsive
well we'll get to the airmen in just a
minute sir
a moment ago you said that you ordered
lieutenant kendrick to tell his men
that santiago wasn't to be touched
that's right
and lieutenant kendrick was clear on
what you wanted
crystal uh so
hard for a witness to know what another
person
was thinking um he's opining about the
mental state of another person
uh that's probably speculation
and probably wouldn't be allowed in in
most courts
any chance lieutenant kendrick ignored
the order
ignored the order any chance he forgot
about it
no any chance lieutenant kendrick left
your office and said
the old man is wrong no
well lieutenant kendrick spoke at this
point there's no foundation
being laid as to how the colonel would
know
any of this information it's possible
that he would
but you're not allowed to just go up
there and ask someone to talk about
things that other people did without
laying the proper foundation
that um that they have the personal
knowledge to
know what actually happened you can't
just say i gave an order
and i know everyone is always going to
to follow that order although i think
that that's sort of the point
the trap that uh that tom cruise is
laying here
well lieutenant kendrick spoke to the
platoon and ordered them not to touch
santiago any chance they ignored him
you ever served in an infantry unit son
no sir so generally witnesses are not
allowed to ask
questions of the attorney when they're
on the witness stand the attorney is the
only one
that's allowed to ask the questions here
and tom cruise would be
well within his rights to ask the judge
to instruct the witness to answer the
question he's being non-responsive
but at the same time he's employing a
tried and true
strategy of giving the witness uh rope
so that they can hang themselves
here we know that the jack nicholson is
is going to make some crucial admissions
in just a second
and by giving him the freedom to uh do
these things that you wouldn't normally
do on the witness stand
uh he's falling into the trap that tom
cruise has laid here
yes sir are we clear are we clear
crystal crystal
colonel i have just one more question
before i call airman o'malley and airman
rodriguez
if you gave an order that santiago
wasn't to be touched
and your orders are always followed
and why would santiago be in danger
so technically this is an argumentative
question the
uh argument is uh integral to the
question itself it's one of those
questions that's like
uh you know when did you stop beating
your wife well that implies
the argument that you were in fact
beating your wife so here
it's the same sort of thing where uh
he's he's laid this trap and and
created an argument through the question
itself that jack nicholson
can't really answer the question without
falling into the argument that's being
made
so it's not technically a proper
question but by the same token
he's simply using the witness's words
against them and uh
some nice legal trickery why would it be
necessary
to transfer him off the base
santiago was a substandard marine
he was being transferred not what you
said you said he was being transferred
because he was in great danger that's
correct
you said he was in danger i said grave
danger you said israel recall what i
said yeah the court reporter read back
to you i know what i said i don't have
to have it read back to me like i'm
white in two orders uh so a couple
things going on here number one
you're not allowed to interrupt the
witness and nor is the witness generally
allowed to interrupt the attorney
uh that that is sort of the definition
of badgering the witness and
uh it's also muddying up the record as
well uh tom cruise uh
eludes to the stenographer who is typing
away
every word that's being said and that's
generally standard practice in almost
any trial
and the attorneys are allowed to read
back
portions of the record to the witness to
to get their clarifying statement
however the judge is not going to allow
the attorney and the witness to talk
over each other because it's impossible
for the stenographer
to record two voices at the same time
and that simply
muddies the record which is the last
thing you want because
you have to have a pristine record in
order to take
an appeal from the trial
colonel
sometimes men take matters into their
own hands no sir you made it clear just
a moment ago that your men never take
matters in their own hands your men
follow orders or people die
so santiago shouldn't have been in any
danger at all should he have colonel
that's more argument snotty little
bastard you're on i'd like to ask for a
recess
i'd like to answer the question judge
the court will wait for an answer
if lieutenant kendrick which is funny
because
he asks for an answer to the question he
just asked
uh and then proceeds to immediately ask
another question
if you have a good question and you need
an answer to it you are allowed to
petition the judge
to uh to instruct the witness to answer
but um you shouldn't then immediately
ask
another question lawyers actually do
this all the time they forget
the sequencing of the questions this
happens both in court and in depositions
uh but it's not uh it's not a good way
to lay a uh a proper record
lieutenant can recorded the code red
denny because that's what you told
lieutenant kendrick to do
objective when it went bad you cut these
guys loose your honor are
inside a body transfer your honor you
doctored the logbook
consider yourself so uh
you are not allowed to yell in court uh
that is uh
completely improper also it ruins your
image
in front of the jury credibility is
everything in front of the jury
and if you are this hothead who's
yelling in court you're going to ruin
your rapport with the jury um and so
you're not going to see a lot of yelling
in court in the way that tom cruise and
kevin bacon are doing here son we live
in a world that has walls and those
walls have to be guarded by men with
guns
who's gonna do it you you lieutenant
weinberg
i have a greater responsibility than you
can possibly fathom
you weep for santiago and you curse the
marines
you have that luxury you have the luxury
of not knowing what i know
that santiago's death while tragic
probably saved lives
and my existence so it's it's a great
line
and uh man it makes for for a good movie
but uh you're never gonna see these kind
of perry mason moments
in court by the time you get to court
you've been preparing for weeks your
attorney has gone over every conceivable
question that you're going to be asked
um and they were are going to help you
uh craft the testimony itself
and uh so the trials are won and lost on
the evidence and the documents
um they are not won and lost on uh
assuming that
the witness is going to go nuts on the
stand and go into a shouting match
match where they basically admit guilt
uh that's not gonna happen
i don't give a damn what you think you
are entitled to
did you order the code red i did the job
did you order the code
you're goddamn right i did
i have never once seen a witness admit
to
uh the crime or the uh civil act
that they are accused of on the witness
stand um
just doesn't happen somehow witnesses
know that their
their ass is on the line and uh they're
not willing to
uh admit to something that's against
their interest it
just doesn't happen very often the next
scene comes from the classic
legal movie 12 angry men
what actually happened is this the boy
stayed home
had another fight with his father
stabbed him to death
and left the house at 10 minutes after
12. he even remembered to wipe the knife
clean her fingerprints
now are you trying to tell me that this
knife really fell through a hole in the
boy's pocket someone picked it up off
the street went to the boy's house
and stabbed his father with it just to
test its sharpness no i'm just saying
it's possible the boy lost his knife and
if somebody else stabbed his father with
a similar knife it's just possible
this is a really interesting
conversation amongst uh
jurors in the jury room after the trial
has concluded
a criminal trial has a very very high
burden of proof
you have to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt and you'll never get any
any judge to tell you what
mathematically that's supposed to be but
a lawyer's shorthand
would be that beyond a reasonable doubt
uh has to be between
95 and 99 uh
sure before you're allowed to convict
someone as opposed to
the civil arena which is where i have
practiced
where you only have to be 51 sure you
have to be
you have to show your cases true more
likely
than not so that's essentially 51 uh
proven um but a a criminal trial has a
much higher burden of proof
so this jury is debating
uh this very high level is a coincidence
enough to show
reasonable doubt and that's an open
question and it's
the question that they should be
debating take a look at this knife
[Music]
it's a very unusual knife i've never
seen one like it
neither had the store keeper who sold it
to the boy aren't you asking us to
accept a pretty incredible coincidence
i'm just saying a coincidence is
possible and i say it's not possible
[Music]
where did you get it i went out walking
for a couple of hours last night
i walked through the boys neighborhood i
bought that a little pawn shop just two
blocks
from the boy's house it cost six dollars
so um the jury is doing the right thing
by debating whether
the prosecution has proved their case by
a reasonable doubt however
a jury is not allowed to bring in
additional evidence
outside of what was presented to them by
the prosecution and told to them
by the judge that's completely improper
this jury would probably be disbanded
and
a mistrial declared uh for this kind of
um this kind of act that goes beyond
what a jury is allowed to do
it's against the law to buy ourselves
switchblade knives that's right i broke
the law
listen you pulled a real bright trick
now i suppose you're telling me what it
proves
however the defendant in this case uh
would have been well served if his
lawyers had done what peter fonda does
here
and actually gone out to see where
someone could buy this really unusual
knife because
it stands to reason that um if it is
a completely unique knife then that is
very probative
of the idea that he committed this
murder however if it's a very common
knife
you know these jurors don't know whether
it's common or not so they should have
been presented with evidence
in the trial as to whether the knife is
common or not but they
should not have brought the knife into
the jury room maybe there are ten knives
like that so what
maybe there are but what does it mean
you found another knife like it what's
that the discovery of the age or
something
you mean you're asking us to believe
that somebody else did the stabbing with
exactly the same kind of knife
the odds are a million of one it's
possible but not very probable
that is a classic distinction in
criminal law between something that is
uh impossible or probable or
coincidental
you'll often hear on tv and movies that
the evidence is circumstantial well the
evidence is almost
always circumstantial that's not a
criticism of the evidence it doesn't
mean that
circumstantial evidence can't be
incredibly strong the circumstantial
evidence here is
probably pretty strong it's unlikely
that another
murderer used a similar or exactly the
same knife
direct evidence is the opposite of
circumstantial evidence which would be
someone actually watching the event
taking place for example
circumstantial evidence can be very
strong just because someone says the
evidence is circumstantial
doesn't mean that it's not uh it's not
good evidence and uh that's what the
jury is debating here
you know it's interesting that he'd find
a knife exactly like the one the boy
bought
what's interesting about it interesting
i don't know i just thought it was
interesting there's still 11 of us here
who think he's guilty
right what do you think you're going to
accomplish you're not going to change
anybody's mind
so if you want to be stubborn and hang
this jury go ahead the kid will be tried
again and found guilty sure as he's born
that's probably right okay the next
video comes from the classic legal movie
and justice for all and ladies and
gentlemen
the jury the prosecution
is not gonna get that man today
no because i'm gonna get him
my client the honorable henry t
fleming should go right to
[ __ ] jail and the son of a
[ __ ] is guilty okay
so uh al pacino has had it with the
system
he's the defense lawyer for uh this uh
this uh defendant
and he has had it with the defendant
and he says my client is guilty a couple
problems with this
uh lawyers have a duty to their client
um every state has uh rules of
professional conduct
for the attorneys and every defendant is
entitled to a zealous advocate
al pacino has uh basically given away
all of his duties to his client and
basically
conceded on his client's behalf of the
client's guilt
now uh that may present some big
problems for
al pacino later on down the line um
he's probably going to get disbarred um
you are not allowed to take action that
is contrary to the
um benefit of your client um and
uh if he had problems with his client
the
the proper remedy would be to ask the
court to
uh remove him from the case and uh to
give his client
time to find uh other representation uh
it is not proper
to admit to the jury that your client
is guilty um he will uh
he'll he'll likely get disbarred for
that action so
here uh al pacino has uh violated
many of the rules of professional
conduct and he's likely to be disbarred
pretty quickly after this outburst in
court
if he's allowed to go free then
something really
wrong is going on you are out of water
you're out of water
you're out of order the whole trial is
out of order
get out of order yeah so
if you um uh if you start yelling at the
judge like this
uh and you violate the judge's
instructions which al pacino is doing
you're very likely to be held in
contempt of court
the judge has an enormous leeway to
keep the order uh in his courtroom
and one of the ways he can do that is by
sending attorneys to jail
um so it's pretty rare uh but this is an
instance
where uh where
really contempt is probably in order al
pacino
may go to jail here um and frankly
this outburst is so prejudicial to the
client
that uh frankly i think the judge would
probably
declare a mistrial which means that he
would disband the jury and they would
start the trial all over again
with a different jury pool that man
sex all right crazy
and he liked to do it again
okay the next scene comes from the dark
knight
sorry i'm late folks
where were you where did you have to
step up harvey i know these briefs
backwards well good
fair is fair heads i'll take it until
he's all yours oh yeah you want to flip
a coin to see who leads it's my father's
lucky coin
as i recall it could be my first date
with you and leave something like that
up to chance
i don't i make my own luck
all rise
uh so there uh often is some contention
about who's going to handle
uh cases in a high-profile case like
this
almost always the uh a senior attorney
would would handle it and so it's
unlikely that
a junior prosecutor or district attorney
would get to handle such a high profile
case in this case however
if um if the da didn't show up then the
the junior deputy
uh would probably have to handle i
thought the d.a just played golf with
the man things like that
t-offs 130 more than enough time to put
you away for life sally
sometimes the head d.a is not the best
person to
try a case sometimes they're just uh
political head who
uh run the department rather than
actually conduct the trials
someone must have stepped up to run the
so-called family
is that man in this courtroom today
could you identify him for us please you
win counselor
it was me
i have a sworn statement from you that
this
man salvatore moroni is the new head of
the falcone crime family
moroni in the criminal world uh there
aren't depositions beforehand
however the police may take a statement
or the da may take a statement from a
witness
and you can use that statement to
impeach
the testimony of the witness on the
stand in the civil world
there are very likely to be depositions
which means that you'll ask
questions and answers and if the witness
deviates
from what was in their deposition then
you are allowed to bring that up
to uh the trier effect and show that
they
cannot be trusted that they break their
word um and that's sort of what is going
on
with the statement that i have a sworn
statement i mean you're not allowed to
literally just
hold up a sworn statement you are
allowed to enter into evidence and to
question the witness about it
but you know they're uh they're taking
some liberties here maroney
he's a fall guy i'm the brains of the
organization
order permission to treat the witnesses
hostile granted hostile
so funny story that actually happened to
me in court and i also punched the
witness
i'm kidding the next scene comes from
aaron brockovich let's be honest here
20 million dollars is more money than
these people have ever dreamed of
oh see now that pisses me off first of
all
since the demur we have more than 400
plaintiffs in
let's be honest we all know they're more
out there uh
so that's uh interesting legal jargon
that's actually fairly accurate this
seems like a settlement discussion
between the defense and the prosecution
and uh what julie roberts has said there
is that after the dimmer
they've gotten more plaintiffs which uh
a dimmer is like a motion to dismiss the
defendants
tried to dismiss the case out of hand um
but they obviously lost and since that
time
uh the the uh defense side has found
uh even more plaintiffs this is a
class-action lawsuit
so the more plaintiffs and the more
injured parties potentially
uh the the more recovery uh
maybe on the table but by the same token
um the more members of a class uh
the uh the less money every individual
plaintiff is going to get if you have to
take the pie and
spread it up into uh more payments then
they're not likely to get nearly as much
so
20 million dollars may sound like a lot
but if it's spread out amongst
hundreds or thousands of people which is
what julia roberts is saying
is happening they may not get very much
personally into their own pockets
they may not be the most sophisticated
people but they do know how to divide
and 20 million dollars isn't [ __ ] when
you split it between them
second of all these people don't dream
about being rich
they dream about being able to watch
their kids swim in a pool without
worrying that they'll have to have a
hysterectomy at the age of 20
like rosa diaz a client of ours or have
their spine deteriorate like stan bloom
another client of ours so before you
come back here with another lame
lame-ass offer
i want you to think real hard about what
your spine is worth mr walker
or what you might expect someone to pay
you for your uterus miss sanchez
then you take out your calculator and
you multiply that number by a hundred
anything less than that is a waste of
our time
so she is hinting at uh one of the
crucial
uh elements of a civil lawsuit which is
that
it is supposed to uh provide
compensation for injury that you
actually
incurred and uh in this particular case
there was uh it's it's actually based on
a real case
uh in california where a community's
water was poisoned and as a result they
had very high
incidences of cancer and other
deleterious
ailments and so if you tried every
individual one of these cases
each individual might get hundreds of
thousands of dollars if not millions of
dollars
from a party if they were responsible
for it
but because it's a class action they're
all lumped together
and julie roberts is saying basically
you need to compensate
every single one of these people for the
injuries that they incurred
and not just provide what seems like a
large number
in the aggregate when you have to spread
it out amongst a lot of different people
so it's a good negotiating tactic it's a
good way to anchor
uh your uh your position um and it's
pretty common amongst class actions
by the way we had that water brought in
special for you folks
came from well in hinckley that's
hilarious
i think this meeting's over damn right
it is
so that's a fairly accurate depiction of
what happens when you have
two sides negotiating amongst each other
when you have just the parties
themselves it gets uh heated very often
and that's why it's it's so common to
have a neutral third party
a mediator come in and mediate the two
sides
i've used a mediator many times it
really helps advance the ball
the mediator can't force anyone to do
anything
but they can provide some external
validation and they can
move things along it's uh it's really
money well spent
um to make sure that you don't reach an
impasse in a negotiation like what
happens here
good morning good morning good morning
ed
erin what's this man yep
go ahead well you know what
mr potter we completely forgot your
birthday this year and
seeing as how you've been so good to me
seemed a terrible
oversight so what ed and i have been
doing the last few days is putting
together a present for you
634 they're all signed
every single one holy [ __ ]
now don't go getting jealous teresa we
have something for you too
this is actually a really interesting
part of the law that you almost never
see
uh in movies and television uh erin
brockovich involves a class action
lawsuit one that actually took place
and part of a class action lawsuit is
the idea that
you have a a small
subsection of the total number of people
that were harmed
called representatives and they
represent a class
of people uh that have been harmed and
so
you say that these people are
representative of the entire class and
therefore
uh whatever compensation the
representatives get should be given to
the entire class
and what erin brockovich has done is
she's gone out and she's gotten
declarations from
600 people saying that they were harmed
and so
effectively they have 600 people
representing the class
and that's important because defense
attorneys try
to defeat a class by showing that
class representatives uh don't represent
the class
or their claims are unusual or there are
a whole number of reasons
why you would defeat a class action by
um disqualifying one or two class
members and often
class actions only have a single class
member or maybe two or three
so erin brockovich has gone out and
she's gotten six
over over 600 people to say that they
want to be members of the class which
really strengthens
uh the class action lawsuit that they're
trying to bring so you don't hear about
that part of class actions very often
but that is pretty accurate to
what uh plaintiff's attorneys uh try and
do in the class action context
how did you do this well
um seeing as how i have no brains or
legal expertise and ed here was losing
all faith in the system am i right oh
yeah completely no faith no faith
i just went up there and performed
sexual favors 634 [ __ ] in five days
i'm really quite tired
so those are some of my favorite legal
movies some are more realistic than
others but it's always fun to see how
hollywood thinks lawyers react in real
life
if you'd like to see more lawyer reacts
videos or hear about my law school
experience or
more legal war stories please click on
this short
playlist that i put together it includes
the latest video i did on law school
horror stories i think you'll really
like it
please click subscribe if you like this
video so that you never miss the next
one
and otherwise i'll see you in the next
video